we were at brunch yesterday and this  like table of people walking by and they  recognized me and they were like yo girl  to find it's been like five years five  years and people are still saying that  bro people that [ __ ] Series yeah I  don't know if it'll follow us forever oh  yeah people at shows will will shout  [ __ ] and I'll go what what and they'll  repeat it I'll go what are you talking  about and they'll go Ooze from and  they'll quote some like random that's  cringe video and I'll go 2005 years ago  I don't remember that  I love you man but I don't remember that  at all the rules of reverse in that case  you're the guy that's like wait what  what what the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ]  Camu powder  what  I don't remember that I don't know